welcome back to las vegas now
recognizing the symptoms of an
overactive bladder can be life-changing
for many we checked in with the urology
specialist of nevada the sponsors of
this next segment for answers
so obviously a lot of women and men are
affected you know on their day-to-day
lives with bladder issues but let's
break it down a little bit let's talk
about an overactive bladder can you tell
us a little bit more about that and what
that really means of course so
overactive bladder um is also known as
urge urinary incontinence
it is the involuntary loss of urine
associated with a sudden urge to go
very common can affect up to 25 million
americans
75 to 80 of those are women mostly over
50.
um and very very common very treatable i
think a lot of people maybe feel
embarrassed to go to the doctor for this
and even once they're there to to bring
it up and be open about discussing it so
what are some tips or advice you have
for people who may be struggling with
this and want to get in and see a
specialist exactly so
i think understanding that they're not
alone not the only ones going through
this that it does interfere with quality
of life it can affect your ability to
work
sleep socialize travel perform daily
functions so knowing that again it is
very common it is very treatable and
let's talk about treatments what types
of treatments are available to those out
there who might be suffering from this
we we start from very conservative to
more invasive so first and foremost we
talk about behavioral modifications
timed urination
avoiding
lots of fluids in the evening hours we
talk about pelvic floor exercises so the
the
the pelvis sits on a muscular floor and
strengthening that pelvic floor can you
can suppress the urge to void i even get
physical therapists involved there are
physical therapists who have special
training in female pelvic disorders they
can teach you again number one where
those muscles are number two how to
strengthen and rehabilitate them we talk
about lifestyle modifications uh
avoiding things which might be
irritating to the bladder the big
culprits there being coffee sodas teas
etc
spicy foods and um
a nicotine big big big bladder irritant
so stop smoking etc and then we move on
to medications there's different types
of medications we use all which
help to improve the ability of the
bladder to store urine beyond
medications we do use botox in the
bladder so just like folks get botox
elsewhere to kind of decrease muscle
spasticity we can do botox in the
bladder to improve the ability of the
bladder to store urine and there are uh
there is nerve stimulation we do by
providing low level stimulation to
nerves that supply the bladder that too
so that's kind of getting a little bit
more advanced but again anywhere from
just some lifestyle changes to
medications to the to the more advanced
yeah as i tell my patients not always
can we cure incontinence but we can
definitely improve it
thank you again to the urology urology
specialist of nevada for sponsoring that
segment they have four locations across
southern nevada where they can help you
or your loved ones for more information
call 702
877-0814 or visit usonb.com
we'll be right back